e
e e
so I will open the finance division
two uh work session and I think we'll be
starting
with well does anybody else have any
comments before I get what we're
starting with
okay we'll start with HB
129 relative to the definition of the
term evidence-based within public
education and I believe the department
is here so do you want to come on
up good morning Melissa white division
director for learner Support Department
of Education thank you so I'll open it
up to questions from the committee
do any questions
sure thank you Mr chair
um I come out of an education background
from decades and decades ago um and
there was a lot of talk around
evidence-based education and you know
basically fine you know evidence is a
good thing um the question I have here
which maybe you can clarify a little bit
is that where is the evidence coming
from from that these things are
effective do you you see what I'm saying
I mean there's we can with Statistics
with everything I can prove anything's
effective anything you know there's
evidence for everything under the sun
especially these days and so can you
speak to your criteria of what you
consider to be actually evidence-based
um educational practices thank you for
the question and the proposed
legislation they have outlined two items
um reproducibility in multiple
well-designed studies within a single
discipline and then the second one is an
independent confirmation by
well-designed studies across multi
multiple
disciplines it conflicts with the
federal
definition um the federal definition of
evidence-based
um is broken up into four different
tiers and so when we're looking at
evidencebased practices there's tier one
which is strong evidence and then tier 2
moderate evidence tier three promising
evidence and then tier four demon
demonstrates a rationale logic models
and that type of thing and then there's
experimental studies that are part of
each of those tiers and so it gets
confusing because most of the
um Mo most of the um research that is
done and clear National whatw Works
Clearing House kind of cataly logs all
of those practices all of those
curriculums and that type of thing and
so often what schools will do is go and
look into what works Clearing House to
kind of find the the research behind
some of these practices some of these
curriculum materials and so that becomes
a little bit of a challenge idea also
has um kind of a separate
definition and so this gets a little bit
tricky because the evidence-based
methods requirement all methods
delivering public education shall be
evidence-based including the educator
training policies and any pedagogical
methods and then it goes into talking
about attached or accompanying
curriculum this gets really challenging
because it's pretty restrictive this
would mean a complete overhaul of
everything that is being taught in a
school so this is in addition to some of
the laws that we have passed one that
comes to mind right off the top of the
head is the memorization of times tables
and the cursive handwriting requirement
there's no that's not evidence-based
that's out that would be out the current
uh Civics law that we pass for requiring
Civics education in the state of New
Hampshire that's not evidence space we
just spent a million dollars on having
that curriculum developed for K to 12
that would be we'd have to um completely
get rid of that um the requirement for
the Civics examination where the
students have to pass the naturalization
test 128 question tests that would be in
violation that's not evidence-based so
these are just a few examples but when
we get into you know suicide prevention
training of teachers all of these
different things don't meet this very
strict definition we do have some uh
legislation that was passed in regards
to um reading instruction and so the
evidence-based requirement for reading
instruction for students that are
um identified as needing those intensive
supports or uh may qualify under the
dyslexia
law that makes sense because it's a very
prescribed
intervention um some of our programs
like title one that talks about
delivering specific interventions to
those students that are demonstrating
they have the most needs for it could be
a math or a reading
intervention that is evidence-based
because you want to ensure that that
intervention they're receiving has some
sort of um scientific study that's been
done to back it up so I think this would
be a
substantial impact particularly at the
local level to have to redo their
entire curriculum to meet the
requirements and then the department
would need a posi at least a position to
be able to implement this because this
is something that's so Loft
we wouldn't be able
to follow through on all the
requirements that are are laid
out representative hacken Phillips thank
you um thank you for that explanation I
think it really centers us on uh the
challenge uh ahead of us here um if if I
am I am acknowledging the local impact
um since we know that our local school
districts are largely in charge of you
know
implementing um education across the
state so I think that's for sure
acknowledgeable um I'm I'm just
wondering about the
states um you know the impact to the
state so I'm looking at the fiscal
note and it states the Department's
estimate for this position including
salary and other costs is 118,000 for
fiscal year 26 23 for fiscal 27 and 127
and fiscal 28 so that would be the
potential new position to kind of
oversee this at the state level so
that's um that's not appropriated in
this bill um at least I'm not seeing it
um and then
um I'm just wondering is there is there
further impact that the state might feel
from possible Federal funding not coming
to us because of this definitional
change is that something that could I
mean you just spoke about a technical
conflict in the definition between
federal law and state law and then I'm
wondering if that could impact the like
the flow of funding you know for title
programs thank you for the question I
think I do not think it will have an
impact on our federal funding
I now that you're saying and I'm
thinking trying to think of through on
the spot here and I'm pretty sure it
would be I think our federal funding
would be okay
um the federal funding that's coming to
the state the pass through component of
it that's where um The Challenge would
lie because if you're looking at what
some of the schools might or the elas
might be um putting into their
activities so that they can get
reimbursed I mean we'd have to take a
look at that
so it's it's possible that we would just
have to re R
structure how we were ex evaluating the
activities they submit to us for um for
their Grant
programs thank you for the question that
was a good
question represent Murray thank you
again so what I hear you saying is that
this sounds pretty unworkable or it' be
a very heavy lift for the department and
also
um the F the the phys the fiscal demands
on local schools uh we don't have any
understanding of what that would be and
that puts me in mind of Representative
lad's Bill about how to um accommodate
funds that to to include funds that
aren't generally included but um at the
Department of Education level but exist
at a local school district level that
don't fit into they don't fall into um
our general buckets of funding so you
know what you know what I'm talking
about you see that there's
there's but he's trying to get away with
unreported um funding at local level you
know where we say you have to you know
teach this class and well there's no
Finance Financial impact on this level
there is because they have to hire a new
teacher and that kind of gets lost in
the in The Fray here and it sounds like
there's a lot of funding here that would
be impact at the local level would have
to bring up money in order to do this um
but it's money that would not
necessarily show up on our fiscal
notes um thank you for the question I I
I think that is
correct when you look at different
content areas those are not necessarily
evidence-based so what consumer
economics could be an example of one of
them might be taught maybe Arts maybe m
i mean there there's certain scientific
studies that may be done for music but I
mean this would be requiring us to go
down this Rabbit Hole of really digging
up trying to
justify I guess what it is we're doing
in schools um the and you're talking
about curriculum materials you know
books and libraries and that type of
thing I mean none of that is necessarily
evidence-based other
questions what do you all want to do you
want to get a caucus and figure it out
or Mr chair I I just I as members of
finance committee are well aware we've
got significant challenges running into
the budget uh cycle this session and um
I'm not sure how we can
justify a new program with this big of a
footnote that's not technically
appropriated
um I'm just having a hard time
reconciling the big job we have ahead of
us of like trying to tighten our belts
according to the governor aot's you know
suggestion and request but at the same
time expanding programs for our state so
I'm having a hard time with that I'm not
sure if there are other members of the
committee having that same
struggle repr papovich thank you Mr
chairman I would suggest that probably
at this point in time you know I'd like
to retain it and if we have time to see
if some of these concerns can be
addressed great if not retaining it will
take it off the table because I agree
that right now we have bigger fish to
fry and I don't want to spend a lot of
time right now on this if we can find
sometime later on the back end that's
great but for now I would suggest
retaining do you want to make a motion
represent
Pap thank you Mr chair I'd like to make
a motion to retain hb1
129 whenever the clerk is ready just oh
yes sorry just for the record this is I
want to you know make it clear that I
cons I'm fine with retaining but I
consider this to be an unworkable
program and a program that could be
incredibly costly and uh given our this
session it's it's fine to retain it if
you know I would like to see it go away
this is just not a workable program um
so I think you know we probably have the
votes to retain it um but it is
certainly a bill I do not
support thank you any other comments
representative
Kelly thank you I have real concerns
about what this is doing at the local
level if we're continuing to downshift
some of our costs there and right now
the schools are
really under pressure for that so I have
that concern as
well any other
comments all right whenever you're ready
um arbs
on
Rush okay it's like a date all
right is all right
first representative papich M
yes representative Harry Bean yes
representative Susan
Dy representative Kenneth Wilder who's
not here representative Kate Murray yes
okay
representative hack hackins Phillips
hackin Phillips yeah it's like a
computer hack hack in philli hack in
anyway that's right hack in Phillip
there you go okay thank you and yes
that's a yes all right uh representative
Kelly yes and representative chairman
Keith
Earth
yes okay all
right okay so we have one two three four
five six seven Ys and no Nays
motion
passed and let me know when you're
ready I'm done that thank
you all right so I'll close the hearing
on
29 and open the hearing on
133 which department of safety is that
this who this impacts so I'll invite the
department of safety up thank you thank
you thank
you good morning Mr chair members of the
committee thank you uh my name is John
morasco and representative it's m
rco and I'm here today with um assistant
director Jennifer Bailey on the DM uh b
a i l e y
want to thank you for the opportunity to
uh to address you this morning uh we
we've worked uh I I've had conversations
with the sponsor um prior to the bill
being um being uh put forth and uh we've
gone through it uh Jen did a wonderful
job with the um uh the fiscal note on it
and as you'll see within the fiscal note
um it would be the technology upgrade of
$40,000 which uh is included within the
bill um but then there would be a
full-time position that would um would
have to handle the um the correspondence
going out and the responses coming back
in which in speaking with the sponsor um
on during any given election cycle he
said we could be looking at uh you know
a couple thousand or more of these
situations where the DMV would be tasked
with mailing uh information out and then
trying to uh get information back or
proactively inquiring why somebody
hasn't um got got a New Hampshire
license after they voted with a notate
90 days prior um and Jen on the fiscal
mode any thoughts you have yeah are did
you guys have questions that you were
want to start with this or did you just
want to hear from us uh either way if
you have comments You' like to make go
go for it both um so the fiscal note
does um so the bill calls for $40,000
allocated to us through the bill to for
the system updates um I added a position
needed because talking to our Tech Team
although we can work Secretary of State
if they were to give us a spreadsheet of
the information which would include a
person's first name last name their
address New Hampshire address plus their
out ofate address and their date of
birth we could upload that into our
system to look for potential matches but
there's going to be those cases where
there's not an exact match or if you
have a John Smith there could be several
matches so there has to be a manual
process in there where we're vetting um
the responses and then there is no way
for our system to just send an notice
we'd have to do those notices manually
um so that's where that position comes
into play um secondly part of the bill
also doesn't only involve voting it also
involves just anyone in general not
getting a license within 60 days which
that's hard to track um can it be
tracked by if they get a ticket in the
state or if they registered their
vehicle yes but that could also add to
that position needing to do that
research of someone here over 60 days
without transferring their
license representative hacken trps
thanks so you just spoke about um the
need to mail out correspondents and then
receive it back so is is the postage
estimate included in this uh fisal note
either so this is not included in this
okay thank you
no no you represented Dy is it possible
for this position to be
part-time um or temporary it depends I
think where we don't know the amount of
work we're going to have um they have an
estimate of a couple thousand per voting
but again we
also the real kind of up in the air is
this first part of the bill that's just
saying in general anyone who's been in
the state over 60 days that's going to
be more of a research position um so
unknown if it could be part-time okay
thank
you representative muray thank you very
much
um usually when you know we've moved
someplace one of the first things we've
done is to get our driver's license set
up and register to vote and all that
stuff um do you you you're in the field
here is this a sense that this is a
problem because
um I hear what the bill is doing I can
understand that um it's going to cost
the money it sounds like it's going to
be cost more money than what's in the
bill and you're not entirely sure how
much more that's going to cost you also
don't seem to know how heavy a lift this
could be in terms of you don't know you
you can't anticipate how heavy um a lift
it will be how much more work it would
be um am I hearing this right is or I
guess back to my original question um do
you feel that there's a substantial
enough problem that we need to address
this during this budget cycle so
representative that was a great summary
um I I don't I don't think we I don't
know the answer to that other than in
speaking with the sponsor uh in depth
about the bill before it was proposed um
you know he's saying that there's uh
several thousand that would need
correspondents to go out so I think the
main focus of the bill is somebody votes
with a out ofate driver's license or out
ofate St non- driver ID um that's that's
where it starts for the 60 days that you
have you've established residency at
that moment because you voted with the
autate ID we can track that it's in the
system 60 days goes by you haven't
applied for a New Hampshire driver's
license the bill gives an additional 30
beyond that so that triggers the DMV at
the 90-day Mark to then do something to
then reach out and inquire and we did
have conversations I I spoke with the
sponsor about is that really the DMV
role um because at the end of the day
um you may have somebody that uh lived
here for a period of time uh and then
moved back to the state that they came
from you may have somebody that uh
stopped driving and didn't apply for a
New Hampshire driver's license because
they didn't want one um or they didn't
want a non-driver ID or need
oneing and so so now you have a
situation where we're reaching out to
people through the DMV to say hey we
noticed that you didn't get a New
Hampshire driver's license and you have
been here for over 60 days why not and I
did Express to the sponsor I'm not so
sure that that's our role I don't know
that we should be doing that so as far
as the scope of the problem with regards
to voting I don't know enough about that
um but with regards to what what is the
end goal because I did ask that question
what so now we send the Corp
correspondents out and nobody gets back
to us there no consequence what what
happens there what happens there is
nothing um and so I did ask towards the
end of the conversation is this more if
we don't get the compliance with the
person that we've reached out to um is
this more of a
research program here are we are we
trying to keep track of information and
and identify patterns that can be used
in the future and the answer to that was
yes I mean there there would have to be
a phase two of this bill at one point
because there were no teeth to it in the
end so basically if if we send something
out and they don't respond that's
essentially where it ends
so represent papovich thank you and I
appreciate you guys being here thank you
Mr chair and thank you for being here to
testify you were mentioning a couple of
other interactions other than voting
right registering a vehicle or
potentially you know getting a ticket
even though with a ticket I could be
from out of state so you know if you
ticket somebody who's got an out of
state license I'm not sure how that
would fall into this but my question is
would there be any other interactions
where you know somebody using an outof
state license could indicate that they
have moved in in and therefore the
60-day time starts because obviously
register a vehicle de giveaway right
voting obviously you just said you live
here same thing for registering a
vehicle tickets I'm not so sure so I'm
just trying to understand is there
anything else in terms of interactions
that you could think of starting a clear
clock on that's a I can I can speak to
that that's a wonderful question
representative and one that we get often
um there isn't uh there isn't so so
really what what you rely on is a
situation where uh law enforcement has
contact with an individual and the
license uh is handed and um it's an out
of state license and the question is
asked oh how long have you lived in New
Hampshire um you're you're really basing
it on the response that you're getting
from the person um there's not enough
time to go back and do a review of their
permanent address and how long they've
been there or you could have a scenario
where a neighbor uh notifies law
enforcement and says I see that this
person has a an out estate license plate
they've been parked in the driveway
there for six months um I I I don't
think they're a New Hampshire resident
or or they they should be a New
Hampshire resident because of the amount
of time that would trigger uh an
investigation that would be something
that you could look into but it's a gray
area the 60 days where the clock starts
is very gray and that's why this bill
one thing it does do is when you
presented the identification at time of
voting that does start the clock the
clock because at that point you've
you've identified yourself through uh an
outstate ID thank you quick
followup thank you so just as a quick
followup the one thing that I can think
of would be you know lease contracts and
whatnot but I would not support any
attempt to go through that in order to
enforce this so that one it's a private
contract between two people I don't want
to have a you know involvement but that
was the only other you know possible
place to get this but again I I I don't
think that it would be worth the effort
policy wise the Privacy violations and
whatnot would be uh not worth the uh
benefits here so I think I'm good thank
you representative I just could I just
add to that for one moment that that's a
great point because at the DMV we
receive information we receive
documentation and I think what's
different about this bill is uh yes we
do send out notices to let people know
that your your license renewal is coming
up um you know your medical card is
going to expire we do communicate we
send out over a million pieces of
Correspondence every year to communicate
um the difference here is to your point
when it comes to um identifying your
address your residency uh we count on
the towns and cities around the state to
do that uh for registration purposes we
do it at the DMVs for licensing purposes
but this one here is almost again maybe
going beyond the scope because you're
reaching out proactively to say we notic
that you haven't received a license yet
and you've been here long enough to get
one please respond as to why I just I
just don't know that that's a a Division
of Motor Vehicles role to be doing that
because a license is a privilege and you
don't have to get one if you choose not
to represent pap
just one followup which I didn't
originally plan but you what you were
saying brought it up can you clarify for
us because this is your area of
expertise uh if you know why do we even
require people to have a New Hampshire
driver's license when they move
in well if it doesn't really matter that
much because they already have the light
right to drive from wherever State they
come in why do we have this so it's a
it's a good question I I can speak to um
the fact that it's in statute um that
you know statute identifies the fact
that the 60-day mark you have to get the
New Hampshire license that being said um
you know you you bring up a great point
on um that gray area really uh somebody
that's here as a visitor um that's not
going to be here for the full 60 days uh
maybe driving with a an international
driver's license which is a translation
document for your home country driver's
license um agricultural visas uh you can
drive and that's in law um but you can
drive on your home country license for
certain visas um for uh up to 300 days
um so there are exceptions to it uh I
can't speak to the original Law the 60
days where it came from and but I we
just follow it but that's a great
question thank you thank you
representative hacka Phillips thank you
Mr chair um thank you I just heard you
say that licenses are a privilege um
which triggered in my mind the idea that
voting is a fundamental right of our you
know
Civic um responsibilities and rights as
Americans so I'm a little I'm drawing
connections now that make me really
uncomfortable so the way I read the law
proposed law here is that it would
require voters to purchase a driver's
license even if they don't drive as an
obligation tied to voting so my question
now is that is that a reverse pole tax
are we talking about charging New
Hampshire
citizens for something they may not even
use or need as as it's correlated to
their right to vote this this seems this
seems like uh tying a fiscal obligation
to voter to voting is what it sounds
like to me and if that's the case that I
have real concerns about its
constitutionality at this point so um I
I'm not in favor of what we're doing
here today
represent papovich thank you and um I
would appreciate if uh you would clarify
my understanding is that we do not
require people to have driver's
licenses we just need a form of ID
driver licens is being one of them but
does the DMV issue non-driver ID and is
there a mechanism through which people
who cannot afford to pay the few dollars
at C can get it for
free so we do issue an option of a
non-driver ID card it's $10 fee um there
is not an option to not pay for that um
however we do per statute I believe back
in the early
2000s um we have a voter identification
card um that is free of charge you get
that a voucher through your town clerk
that you're eligible for if you um don't
have a license or ID card in the state
um you're eligible for that document
thank
you representative P PHS is a followup
to that question um is there any
language in this bill that would suggest
that the voter ID cards would be uh like
an exemption to the rule or there is not
possibility and the voter ID the way
it's written into statute is that you
don't have um a you don't have the
ability to obtain a license so you don't
already currently have an out of state
license you don't already currently have
a New Hampshire ID card it's
for those that may I would say most
commonly we've seen issued that they've
been in nursing homes for years they
don't have their original documents and
they want to vote they can get that
voter
identification representative Kelly as a
followup to that does the voter ID card
have a photo of the person it does it
has very it only puts their photo their
name um address and date of birth
there's nothing much else on
it other
questions I I have one so if the
department of safety isn't the one to
follow up what department would be more
appropriate well um that's a good
question you know we did I did speak
with the sponsor about that too sir I
mean
it we do send information to the
Secretary of State's office for new
residents to the state that get a New
Hampshire credential and they're they're
made aware of that for purposes of the
towns and voting um but to have it come
the other way um so that we can send out
correspondents to try to um identify
status I mean that's really what you're
talking about here right you're you're
trying to identify a person's current
status 90 days after they went in and
voted I I I don't think we are the
agency that should be identifying status
we do it when somebody wants something
like a credential and they bring uh
their information to us the document
documentation to us and we have to
validate status to give you that
credential but in this one here it's
really it has nothing to do with the DMV
but yet we're reaching out to you to
identify your status 90 days after you
voted which to your question sir would
appear to me to reside with Secretary of
State's
office so we have a law which you
referred to which I think you indicated
required a person to get a driver's
license Within 60 days and the last I
checked the DMV is responsible for
issuing driver's licenses I guess I'm a
little confused as to why it wouldn't be
natural for the Department of Safety to
be the one to follow
up um I think I guess my thought on that
would be the the ACT that's taking place
like the Attorney General's office if
somebody uh believes that that there's
been voter fraud if if somebody believes
that somebody voted that shouldn't have
my understanding is that gets sent to uh
the Attorney General's office for review
um so there's a mechanism for that so in
this particular case we're talking about
somebody voting and showing an out ofate
license which we have nothing to do with
uh but they show the out ofate license
to do a certain thing which in this case
is
voting we don't know if somebody went
and voted we don't get involved with
that that's not our scope we we we issue
credentials but yet from that
transaction now it's coming back to the
DMV through uh another state agency that
the Secretary of State's office coming
back to us to sayate this person did
this particular thing which is outside
the realm of what you do but we would
like you on our behalf to reach out to
this individual through correspondence
or put a link on the website to this
individual to get an update on their
status so that it appears to me so that
we can report that back to them right
report that back to them so it it
appears to me that the DMV is is playing
the middleman here and I just don't know
um
how operationally that that works so I
don't know that it resides with us
because we wouldn't do that for I'll
give you another example we get calls
all the time for um businesses scanning
somebody's
license somebody scammed my license I've
read 2614 driver Privacy Act my rights
have been violated I want that person or
business uh investigated and I want an
arrest made we we get those calls um so
but but we don't we don't at that point
reach out to the business uh we don't do
an investigation we don't do it you
somebody has used the license for a
purpose that a citizen believes or
resident believes was inappropriate
that's that's a referral but we don't we
don't get asked to send out
correspondents to pick a business to say
hey we understand that you're doing this
why did you do that you have X number of
days to report back to us on your
practices we don't do that and so I I
think that that's why I say it's beyond
the scope we issue licenses we issue
titles uh we clear defaults and and
suspensions uh we work with the towns
and cities to issue registrations we
don't do
the the behindth work investigative work
that it appears that this bill is
somewhat asking us to do and just to add
to that so the initial bill about the 60
days this is the actual RSA the 26335
this first part of the bill is the
original Bill they're adding this voting
part to it um do I think that the other
means we talked about that if we were
told that they're um they had registered
a vehicle for like last year and now
they're going to renew and they haven't
gotten a New Hampshire license yet do I
think that's in our scope that's in our
scope I believe because we register
vehicles that so I think that's where we
would that part of the original Law we
would reach out to those people that you
haven't transferred but again the Voting
is adding an additional to us where
we're not engaged in any part of voting
otherwise
well if I could just add to that too so
so with with that situation again the
the DMV though in in being go back to
the scenario that I offered before where
a neighbor calls in and says I think
that uh somebody's been here for six
months with a an notate plate and I
don't think they're they've established
residency and I think they should um we
we don't we we don't investigate that we
we don't investigate that that goes to
the state police and the state police a
separate division within the department
of safety would do that investigation
but the dmbb we don't we don't do that
investigation I just want to clarify
that repres papich thank you just a
quick clarification because you know I'm
learning a lot um when I think
investigation I think of way more than
sending a letter and then basically
saying I guess nobody answered right so
I'm just trying to
understand since you guys are the
keepers of the drivers licenses right if
all we are asking to do is not a
full-blown investigation just a request
hey you may not be aware of this law
that requires you to 60 days now we
noticed you've been here more than 60
days and we know that because of again
vehicle regist it doesn't even matter
whether it's voting or registering a
vehicle we are aware that you've been
here for more than six days you may want
to consider right obeying the law and
getting your license right is that that
much of a burden
I I'm just trying to understand I hear
your concerns if you would be asked to
you know
send investigator and talk to people and
interview the neighbors but we're
talking about the letter and then either
you get a response or you don't that's a
great question representative if I may
start with it and certainly uh assistant
director Bailey Can can add to it um I
guess my my thought on that would be
again I see the DMV and I've expressed
this to the sponsor um you know we we've
had a great conversation regarding the
bill but I I see the the DMV sending out
the letter no that's not cumbersome for
us uh you know we like I said we send
out over a million pieces of
Correspondence every year for reminders
for um You' you've got your license 3
roughly 880,000 uh times a year um I
think I think the difference here is
we're we're sending that we're sending
that document out to check on to let you
know that we know that you didn't get a
uh put it this way if somebody that goes
and votes and uses an out ofate ID and
goes about their business and their life
and then they decide you know what I'm
not going to renew my driver's license
and it happens to expire within 60 days
after voting this law says that the
90-day Mark you got to trigger the DMV
and we've got to send out that
correspondant I I don't know I could
Envision people opening their mail and
and seeing wow the DMV logo is on here
the DMV is asking me why I didn't get a
license in New Hampshire why is the DMV
and this has and then they make a phone
call and they find out well why did I
get mailed this letter you get mailed
the letter because you're voted with an
out state ID I think people are going to
start to ask the question why is the DMV
following up on my voting record and I
guess that's a little bit of a concern
that I have I think that that letter is
not cumbersome but I think the letter
probably should come from the Secretary
of State's office you're right we have
the data if you want the data and you
query us to provide in law you the data
for who hasn't gotten the license in the
90 days we'll give you that information
but I say you send the letter out
because this whole things about voting
you didn't get the license it's a
residency thing I get it and it's a
driver license thing I get it but I
think that letter should come from
Secretary of State's office so the
person opening the mail can put two and
two
together representative Murray thank you
yeah I don't think the government should
be the neighborhood Busy Body in
tracking down some of that things and I
just want to refer to page two lines
seven and8 well 6 s and 8 and you can
correct me if I misread Secretary of
State shall authorize release of
information for the database necessary
for the Department of Safety to notify
an individual pursuant to na na na I
just don't see that that's anywhere in
the department of safety's purview um
it's not part of their mission it seems
to me that's part of the Secretary of
State's
Mission represent hacka Phillips thank
you isn't it possible that an elderly
person who previously drove and worked
in another state could move to New
Hampshire for you know assisted living
or you know permanent retirement and
determine that you know they never need
to drive again so they wouldn't need a
driver's license so even if we're
looking at the first section of the
bill um for a non-resident who
establishes residency in the
state I'm having a hard time
understanding why the state would have
an interest in demanding that an elderly
person retiring here in New Hampshire
who doesn't drive is required to have a
driver's license so um again comes with
a fiscal you know obligation for these
folks who probably are limited income so
again I don't understand why they would
be charged to live in the state of New
Hampshire um so I again I think that
there's a lot of work that this bill
needs um to be successful I think the
intention is just not um really carried
out completely with the details and
again I if I could just Express to the
committee the um you know real concern I
think at the back of the fiscal note
here there's several POS unfunded years
of positions here that are not
appropriated in the bill and if I
reflect upon my earlier statement on the
previous bill you
know how can we justify adding a new
program to our state when we know that
there's some serious and significant
cuts that we need to do as a as a budget
committee so I just again um I think
while this bill comes a little closer to
being um thought through it's still a
lot of work needs to be done I
appreciate your time would you believe
that's
true hold on could you just clarify
where you referring to on page
one is it is it section c on line 14 uh
section page so page one of language I'm
looking at lines you know one through
nine um oh the part this current law non
residents who establish residencies in
the state well that's current law though
correct yes yeah but as you go down as
you go down the B subsection B and C I
mean it's requiring people to get
driver's licenses here in the state but
I mean I don't are we requiring every
resident in the city of New Hampshire to
have a driver's license now I
just
yeah um did you have AES represent
Murray yeah um if it's appropriate and
if it's not I can hold off um but given
that I find this again as an unworkable
program I think it's dealing with the
wrong agency I'm not sure that it's a
significant problem or that it's the
department of safety's problem and that
it's a new budget and going to be a
really really tough year there are no
exemptions for the voter ID cards as far
as we can tell with what we're reading
and that um it does seem to have
identified costs since we don't know
what the lift would be I would propose
an itl on this
if the timing is
Right Rob papovich if I may just I had
one last question um who's currently
responsible for enforcing
26335 as current
law 633 yeah the the whole non resident
who establishes a residency in the state
oh
um well I can say from a from a DMV
standpoint um we don't we don't get
involved with that we don't follow up on
that we don't proactively reach out to
identify how long somebody's been in in
the state unless not proactively but
when you get you know the information
again somebody registers a car law
enforcement okay but at at this point in
time when you guys become aware that
somebody has an outof state
license you know and then 60 days later
they still don't have a license in your
system
what is the current process that you
follow well well if I could on that
ticket yeah so so the if you have that
Nexus with law enforcement and it's
identified that the license that's being
given is out of state um and the
person's been here for over this 60 days
then that that is a that's a uh
ticketable offense so there'd be
enforcement action there that would
require that individual um potentially
to appear in court so there's there's
that Nexus um when we talk about
registration ation the example I used
earlier again if if we were to be made
not made aware of the fact that somebody
probably has been in New Hampshire
Beyond um you know the 60-day mark and
therefore should be claiming residency
then what we would we would do is we
would refer that to law enforcement who
would then they would do an
investigation maybe do an interview or
two and prepare a report um that would
then either there would be um law
enforcement action taken or um you could
have a situation where administrative
action is requested by the DMB on behalf
of law enforcement but we would have
them do that we would ask them to do
that on our behalf and it's a clarifying
question go ahead I do have one more
also when you're registering a vehicle
most towns most towns require you to
have a New Hampshire license for your
register those that will register with
an ad ofate if you go back the following
year to renew they will stop you at
renewal time and won't allow you to
renew until you OB that's one year not
60 days right and and again I'm just
trying to understand the current process
right because at the end of the day when
you talk about changing it it kind of
behooves you to understand what the
current process
is
so car registrations which are you know
again processed by the dmbb at the end
of the
day most Town clerks won't let you do it
without a driver's license I find that a
bit surprising because they seem to
exceed state law but I'm not going to
get into that particular with uh
patch but if it's register you know when
you register it and you have an out
ofate driver's license you would be
immediately aware of that right and then
you it's just a matter of the 60 days do
you proactively look at that and say 60
days later I'm going to go look at these
people who we were aware at the time you
know they started the clock and now I
you know I'm going to bring it to the
attention of whoever enforces it or is
that something that you don't do right
now that's an excellent question
representative excellent question we
don't okay we don't we don't track it we
don't do that um ultimately what happens
is uh
we essentially defer to law enforcement
we defer to law enforcement for when
they identify those scenarios um to
either take enforcement action do an
investigation and like I said maybe
notify us administratively of action
they would like us to take because they
have completed an investigation it's a
it's a really good question the
60-day um residency piece is one that
comes up a lot and it's uh there is
there is a gray area to it I mean
there's a gray area to um we hope
everybody does it when they've been here
for 60 days um and if they don't then
they're running a risk of having contact
with law enforcement um and maybe law
enforcement's able to figure that out
thank you thank
you that that time representative
Murray
um instead of this but yeah I do have
the I did propose the itl um going
forward instead of something like this
um would it be helpful to you if the
legislature addressed this gray area
that you're referring to or or is that
just kind of a
meh I I think it's a wonderful question
I I don't have the answer to it I I
don't know I don't know it's it's
definitely it's definitely one that it
would be nice if there were if it was
more clear
in how that could be enforced on the
60-day um but I let me give it some
thought and talk to some other people
and maybe I could get something back to
you all right thank you representative
any thoughts on that off hand
representative papovich just the
enforcement given that we are still
looking at potentially trying to work on
this I would make a motion to retain
this
bill I didn't know you made a formal
motion but okay we can consider that
I'm happy to Second th y when you're
ready uh representative Roy
y
representative I'm sorry
n Representative harb
no so close hacken Phillips yeah it's
like a computer hack or like you're
hacking a tree down with an axe uh and I
vote Yes
yes reprentative
chairman Earth just representative Earth
as
sign no
represent papovich thank you Mr chair
I'd like to make a motion to retain um
HB
133 when you're ready represent no rush
righty
I representative Harry be
yes
no nice and noelly
no
representative
yes to retain pass 4
to thank you and thank you both for
coming this morning appreciate it thank
you
so we're meeting on later is there more
that anybody has to throw down
now I'll take that as a no we're good
what did you have something to say no
I'm good okay you're good okay well
change I'm
quiet so we're back at one is that
correct back at one that sounds right
yes so see you all at
one not quite all of us
and and
I'll uh end the division two meeting um
effective
now
e
e e
it being uh
105 we'll open the work session of
finance division
2 and we'll start with uh Mr landan from
the LBA for presentation um thoughts
about how the next six or seven or
whatever it is weeks are going to
go and is it all right if we just
interrupt you with questions in the
process so of course everybody please
feel free to um you know jump in one of
the goals in addition to him going over
a lot of things is also for us to agree
on how we want to go about um working
with the with the Departments as they as
they come in so that we're on the same
page as far as that goes as I understand
it'll be a little bit different than um
we've done in the past how's that we
we'll get to it okay
Mickey will bring us
there all right good afternoon folks um
so before we get started I just want to
make sure everyone has a lot of the
documents I at least want to point us
through today so last week you got the
big budget document the governor's
recommended budget I see a couple of
those out there so you've got those um
it's also very user friendly in a PDF
form for searching and if you prefer
that method uh as well as the um
Governor's budget executive summary has
some useful information and there I'll
kind of point us to a couple of things
um and then the trailer Bill document
which I think everyone has a copy of
that now and we'll kind of go over that
as well and I'll point you to the
sections that'll likely be referred to
division two um for
review I also handed out a clipped
packet of papers um and we'll get to
these two one um is just a summary of
the total Appropriations by source of
funds for each of the agencies in
division 2 as well as an education trust
fund Highway fund and fishing game fund
Surplus statement you know SL SN uh
snapshot of the governor's recommended
budget and I've I've built a column for
division 2's starting point essentially
which takes into consideration the house
Ways and Means Committee adopted
revenues so that's what I just want to
at least just go over uh these documents
today does everyone have those I think
you all do
uh did you get one that was the one this
morning I think you had on your table is
that it right to your
right yep that that's the trailer bill
yeah so uh so trailer bill is the uh
nickname for what will eventually be
House Bill 2 when it's introduced um
this is not the official introduced
version this is the governor's draft OS
is working on getting an official house
bill to drafted
all
right so I guess uh first thing um we
talked about before we get into some of
these details um what representative
Earth was talking about as far as
process maybe we touch on that first um
in the past um division 2 has had the
agencies come in heard a a presentation
and kind of moved on from there uh prior
to that and I know some other divisions
have done this where you've actually
gone through and flipped the pages I
don't think we've done that in division
two the last term or two but that's
something representative Earth was
considering doing this year I think the
agencies are on board with so that'll
make it important for you to have your
big budget with you or uh your PDF when
the agencies come in they'll be prepared
to start on page one of their budget
flip pages um our agencies have a lot of
accounting units that are federal other
funds um that you probably are not going
to want to spend a ton of time on as
your flipping certainly reasonable to
ask the agency oh what's that grant for
um
but understanding you only have so much
time in this process you probably aren't
going to want to spend a ton of time on
the non General Highway education trust
fund accounts so I think that is that
the big change you were kind of talking
about yes and I would like to get your
feed back in terms of that approach and
perhaps you could also bring up some
example pages of like one that has
federal funds only for instance and one
that has a mixture so people can
understand what it is we're looking at
and and what ones maybe we can just skip
over more rapidly but I'm glad to take
questions first if you prefer I I am
totally down with that I actually missed
going line by line the past I I just
thought it was kind of egregious I
thought that it was um not what is the
word I want it was not a very
professional thing to do not to go line
by line so I'm really and I think my
first two sessions by and large we went
line by line and um I am totally totally
supportive of that it is what I am doing
at my kitchen table at home I'm so glad
to hear that because that's what
division three did representative Kelly
that's what I'm used to so I didn't I
missed this little change that happened
and does it make sense to you what we're
talking about
okay is perfect okay well that's great
that was easy so maybe you just show us
for especially for the new people um
a couple sample pages to get an idea of
about the whole GFF thing that gives so
we understand how where we can move more
rapidly through um because there are a
lot of pages to
flip so I can point you to one right now
because I've got one here if you've got
your document handy so on the big uh
document if we go to page
382 and this would be 382 and this would
be in the department of safety's budget
382 I guess if you've got Adobe or
whatever you're yeah it's the it's
actually the PDF page number so it's
it's or the printed page number is 383
it's actually the document page number
396 in the PDF uh Adobe but what's
printed at the top of the page should be
3833 yeah yeah
Department of Safety three page
383 yeah it it's 382 and then goes on to
383 the account that we'll start with
no yeah so our office would have seen
these for the first time when you did on
last Thursday
are you all set represent Kelly got your
paper it's much easier okay you're all
set as well okay we're good so on the
bottom of 382 you see accounting unit
5046 recreational boat safety Grant and
this continues on to the next page and
you see halfway through the page the
estimated source for funds is federal
funds so this entire accounting unit is
federally funded so this would be a good
example when you get to an account like
this certainly the department maybe in a
sentence or two can hopefully briefly
explain what that Grant's for and how
it's used um but making a reduction
Herer cutting is not going to help your
general fund story in any way um but
certainly it's it's all still authorized
spending it's still within the purview
of this committee to decide what you
want to fund it at but as far as in the
uh effort of Saving Time and everything
you may not want to spend a whole lot of
time there uh yeah absolutely um yeah I
mean going back on the de still remember
the blinding Turtles I'll never forget
the blending Turtles when there was a f
thing but uh sometime one of the things
that confuses me is when something gets
moved from one place to another so
you've got all these zeros here and it
looks like the or you know you have
zeros and then there's money or there's
money and then it's all zeros and trying
to keep track of when something is
actually coming or going and when
something has been switched someplace
else it takes me a while to try to sort
out which it is so any direction there
can be
helpful yeah and that's something we'll
rely on the agencies for so as you're
flipping and you see one of those
examples and I'll actually get to one I
can show you one here soon um we'll have
to ask the agency oh maybe these aren't
seven new positions maybe they were
somewhere else and now they're just
creating a new accounting unit splitting
it out and and and a lot of that we'll
we'll rely on the agencies for the
detail repres Dy are you on this page
regarding federal funds does that make
sense to you if there were multiple
funding mechanisms it would be fed
Federal General other that kind of thing
would be listed down there and if we
continue before we get to that um uh
regarding what you just said oh gez um
things getting moved things get moved
around yeah one big thing you're going
to see is where the
education accounts used to all be in one
account they're now going to be
separated into individual accounts so
that's a huge change that's going to
show up just the way
describing yeah that's a good example
and that's right at the end of the
Department of education's budget we can
we can uh go through that later too if
you'd like but if you flip to page 385
so a couple Pages later this is the
detective
Bureau and we uh we heard the governor
talk about some changes to the detective
Bureau uh so this is an example if you
look at the bottom it's General funds
but then there's some agency income in
here so we would want to ask the
department some details on what that
agency income is but you can see General
funds for this account so this would be
an area you'd want to understand oh
we're going from 68 positions to 77
positions what's going on here so this
is a good account to ask the department
for just to understand what's going on
um and then and this is also one was I
found it interesting to ask so what does
agency income mean y um safety and
others of the account that we're looking
at have a lot of dedicated funds that um
it might be worth exploring whether we
want to keep them as dedicated funds or
take a different approach but in any
case this is one of
them yes yep uh and then if you go to
page 415 I think it could be PDF page
428 represent Murray but it's accounting
unit
5006 mechanical
safety yes
are you there okay so this is an example
of there's nothing for 24 and 25 but we
see nine positions and a full accounting
uh in the trailer Bill we see that um
the electri electric uh inspectors and I
don't want to misquote it but there's
some mechanical safety inspectors looks
like there's proposal to move them from
oplc Back to the Department of Safety
this used to be a function under the
fire safety uh division so not only from
different accounts but from different
divisions right so when uh I know
division one should hopefully be asking
about this when they have oplc in we'll
ask safety about it when when they come
in just to get an understanding of this
looks like a big change just need to
understand what's going on
here does that make sense absolutely go
ahead why why would they do
so that so this this would be something
to ask the department about there could
be a policy reason why they would feel
that the department of safety's division
of fire safety is more suited to do this
work than the office of professional
licensure and that's why the the move
was uh proposed here so you'll you'll
hear from them the um the intent behind
it the reasoning
okay so that's just I think hopefully
everyone's comfortable with this you'll
you'll become experts when the budget
session's over and then not look at it
again for two years that's usually how
it works so just while we're here to
reiterate every account at the end shows
the number of positions of the various
types and that's also very important to
look at to see are they incre and here
you're seeing a big jump which is not
actually real because it's shifting from
a different place but like the one that
Mr L just showed us where it was it
actually was going up they added about
nine new detectives and that was the
governor's you may remember her talking
about um clo um
not closed cases cold cases um that's
that's that's why that's that's why
that's that's what's going on there and
one thing as far as the position counts
go that calculates the total uh funded
permanent CL or not funded the total
permanent classified unclassified
positions not necessarily funded ones so
that accounting unit has nine positions
in there we'll have to rely on the
department to tell us of those nine how
many are funded because we can have
unfunded authorized positions in state
government we have many of them and and
how many are vacant and and either
funded or not funded when when they're
vacant and yeah a position can be uh
authorized not authorized funded not
funded uh filled unfilled so yeah we
would and those would obviously be a
snapshot in time too so the department
could answer questions on those when
when they come in does I'm sorry go
ahead I was just going to ask also one
of the things which you know threw me
sort of in the beginning or it took me a
while to catch up is
the aggregate stuff sort of at the end
of each area where you know we've got
this section and this section and this
section and then at the end you've got
all three sections or 16 sections put
together and um I always needed to keep
reminding myself that this is aggregate
of something that I've already looked at
and it should be obvious but it wasn't
so obvious to me
sometimes yeah this Doc before you
answer that do you understand what she's
saying what she's asking oh yeah
okay this document is uh can be a little
um
mean on your eyes when you're looking
through it and and it it messes with us
too they will subtotal at each change in
an agency and then uh or not agency
activity they call it so it could be the
division subtotal and then there could
be a subtotal for now you've got all the
general fund accounts in that department
then you move to the high it the
subtotals can screw you up for sure yep
so you got to be careful looking at
those so just to continue on so the
agencies will come in they'll they'll
make the presentation I'll do like I
always do if they have requests I'll
compile all those for our list of
outstanding items as well as the retain
bills so this morning we retain two
bills so on my tracking sheets I'll add
those at the bottom just so they don't
fall through the cracks and then the
division at a later date can decide what
to do as you're going along if you want
to make votes and this is where chairman
F I'll defer to you how you want to
operate um it's not uncommon
unprecedented that as an agency's going
through somebody may want to say oh well
I'd like to make a motion to add money
here or reduce money here and then you
can do that and then I can keep track of
everything on the Fly that that's up to
the division we've we've done it in two
ways before um we've done it doing that
we've done it where no actions are taken
until another date and that's up to the
committee so I'll give you my take but
I'm glad to happy to get some feedback I
guess I would be more inclined to have
Mr L make a note of that so we can come
back to it and talk about it as opposed
to keeping the department here talking
about it I mean I'm assuming we would
have already asked them the questions
that would give us the information we're
looking for now it's just a matter of
what we want to do but I'm open to
feedback if you all have a different
point of view well if I can um maybe it
was me I didn't know we were going to
take motions on the two bills we took
motions on this morning so my apologies
so if you know you can give a heads up
that we so here's a heads up whenever
and this is my bad because we're having
this meeting after the bills um if we
have bills on the on the docket if you
will um
they'll always be I think they're always
in work sessions I think we can always
take motions and my my plan is to try to
do it just to get them out of the way
because we have a lot of stuff to worry
about and to basically sit and talk
about it one day and then come back
another day and sit and talk about them
again um so so if there's bills there as
there will be next week I think there's
three maybe next week that we'll be um
considering what to do with them so we
should be we should be prepared to make
a motion every time there's a bill on
the docket yes I was had that would be
the ideal situation yes you can do that
okay um so yeah if if the division wants
to hold off on making budget change uh
motions I guess if you will until
subsequent work sessions with the
agencies aren't here you know doing
their presentation that's fine or even
after they leave is that is that okay
with you sure I'm just thinking rather
than you know if we want to talk about
it I'd rather not tie up the people here
when we're trying to zip through
whatever thousands of pages of their
budget yep yeah I think that's fine I
mean you can keep track of the sure
comment to you yep and and like I said
we'll have I think the last
day that we have an agency schedule for
their initial presentation is Monday the
10th so that will still give us a good
three weeks to have work sessions to
either call back agencies if you need
more information or have a work session
where you just are making motions and
taking votes uh we'll obviously have a
lot of houseu to stuff to get to at some
point too um so yeah the the only
changes that I would
say if you get a lot lot of like
technical changes from the agencies if
they come in and say these are some you
know we should change them they want to
change them if if they if they're like
no impact on your state funds and
they're just cleanup that would help me
too to get those approved earlier in the
process so I can make that those so
totally fine and if you just give me the
high sign if I if I miss that yeah I'll
I'll stop and say and suggest that it
makes sense to just vote on this or
whatever absolutely okay um so that's
all I've got for that document um did
anybody have any questions with in the
governor's recommended budget uh before
you go on yep does anybody else have any
questions about this the big document
okay all right uh the executive summary
included uh the governor's revenues as
well as Surplus statements I I've got
the education trust fund Highway fund
and fishing game Surplus statement
documents we can go through here
separately but did anybody have any
questions for and the one thing that
jumps out at me is like the VT Revenue I
know that's the the video Lottery
terminal re Revenue um I think that's
tripped up some folks with how that's
being done on here um I won't I'll get
into it too when we get to the Surplus
statement
but so in the executive summary the
revenues are on page 13
turn your microphone on and then go
ahead I didn't know we had a v this is
gaming a Video Gaming
revenue so yeah this is a new proposal
and that it's included in in the trailer
bill um it looks like on page 39
if you want to see the the governor's
recommended Law changes associated with
it but I think the idea is to convert
historical horse racing to oh video
Lottery terminals yeah okay I'm sorry
and there's a a significant Revenue
increase associated with doing that if
this goes beyond the so-called what is
it historic horse racing thing um these
are slot
machines and um yeah I think some of us
are struggling with this being rather a
major change to the legislature and
getting it into hb2 is going to be a
real
challenge I don't know how you feel
about slot machines it it is in hp2 so
maybe what you mean is getting it out of
hp2 so
um Charlie McIntyre the Lottery
Commission will be into CS Friday and
they'll be prepared to speak on this so
I think that' be a good time for this
committee to kind of get all those
questions out there because typically
with Lottery we don't have them multiple
times their budgets usually pretty
straightforward this year with a big
gaming policy change they're a little
bit more um involved perhaps in prior
years but we may not have Lottery come
back again so we'll try to get all that
out this
Friday but as far as that Revenue goes
the governor does you see it down on the
uh the table on on page 13 fourth row
From The Bottom the uh VT Revenue $10
million in fiscal 26 and 117 million in
fiscal 27 so big numbers and the budget
does assume half would go to the
education trust fund and half would go
to the general fund that's how and you
may remember representative McGuire's
comments yesterday regarding the the
deficit with with the uh funds of the
legislature versus the funds of the
governor's budget and this is part of
her revenues which obviously are not
included in in ours right
now does that make sense okay happens
that bill doesn't right right what
happens that that bill doesn't pass
we're in trouble well it depends on
first of all it's not a bill it's in hb2
which is a bill but it'd be part of the
budget unless we as representative
Murray was positing take it out of there
but right then it would obviously not be
Revenue if we don't it doesn't get
passed by the house and the
Senate and and just to remind folks how
the process works is all of the house
bill two sections this committee will
vote on even if you want to keep them in
unchanged that's been the practice just
to you're either voting to delete it
voting to keep it in or voting to amend
it in some way so I always like to have
some sort of a vote taken on all the
sections in there just so it's very
clear what division 2's intention was
with with house bu two
recommendations um so that that's all
I've got for the base revenues does
anyone have any questions on on that
page sorry do you know where we are I'm
not sure yeah I'm catching up thank you
um Mickey this question is not really
for you it's more for the chair um I'm
sorry if I missed the discussion already
on the video
revenues um but it seems to me that this
is pretty significant policy change that
would be put in the trailer bill without
a public hearing unless we hold a public
hearing on the entire HB to right so my
concern is that um you know in the past
my understanding is that it's been a
practice of the state to hold public
hearings on large policy changes
and I'm wondering what is the appetite
on your side of the of the of the aisle
to have like a separate hearing for the
V like the slot machine revenues that
the
governor's um suggesting especially when
I think about you know the gap between
the overall Governor's revenues and and
the house initial estimates for revenues
uh from ways the
means you know I'm I'm concerned that we
might be a
little without public input we might be
overstepping our bounds by just enacting
you know accepting the governor's plan
so um I'm just wondering what the
thought pattern is s to be honest I
there hasn't been much thought put into
it yet um and I would say at this point
my one of one of my concerns will be
just time um but I I I hear what you're
saying and I'm not I'm not opposed to it
it's a question of you know getting
getting it all in would but I really
haven't given it a lot of thought and
while we're while I'm speaking um one of
the things we did talk about when you
were not here just to touch base with
you on it we decided to go through and
with the agreement of your colleagues as
well Page by page to the budgets want to
let you know you're you're good with
that okay all
right so you'll make a note of
the excuse
me of the possibility of having a public
hearing so at least that's on the list
things to think about for the V for the
VT thing sure I mean it's that's this
committee can have a work session and
open up to whoever you want on any topic
you want right but I'll forget so I'm
sure I'm sure represent hack and
Phillips but but I want you to remind me
so that I keep thinking about it and and
just to remind everyone we we will have
a public hearing on the budget there's
you know House Bill one and House Bill
two do have a public hearing so that
requirement is is achieved it's not
specific to justs but that's that can be
something that thinking back to last
bayum you know there are a lot of
competing interests in the room when
that when those public hearings take
place and
um you know the the benefit of having a
public hearing on a single you know Bill
going through the full Bill process
procedur is that you hear the pros and
cons from the community you know from
the public so uh when you get to the
house bill to hearing it's more like
people are like we need more money in
our section or you left us out is the
it's not really on the merits of the
program so I when you have a I mean
deciding whether or not to introduce
slot machines into the state is a pretty
big cultural shift because we don't
currently have that so um you know my
concern would be you know are we hearing
from the public enough about I mean of
course we need everybody recognizes the
need for more Revenue in the in the
current cycle but I think um hearing
about the policy merits might be a
separate benefit to the process and just
just to in case everyone wasn't there is
a bill a house bill 728 that is relative
to video Lottery terminals so that'll
have its own hearing and it's not a
senate house house bill 728 um it's I
don't think it's deemed a a second
committee bill so we won't get it at
this the committee deadline of the March
6th but in in theory there should be a
house policy set if that bill does go on
its own and then perhaps that would be
turned in or added to house bill to or
or something like that do we know which
committee is seeing it or if it's been
publicly Ways and Means okay Ways and
Means and no hearing scheduled yet okay
maybe we could put a request in to have
them lover off theirs like maybe we
could do a combo or something I don't
know yeah you could go or just go to it
yeah go yeah so maybe yeah make a note
to of that make that you can track that
for us and let us know and yeah well
yeah if you can encourage them to hold
the soon than later but I leave that in
your
hands yeah well no we have to have all
the bills out of the house before we
done with the budget so so they would at
least have had the public hearing
yeah mistaken about that well bills not
going to a second committee have a
different deadline too so right but our
budget has a even longer deadline or at
least the same deadline correct no it's
it's after yeah so so they would have to
hold the public hearing before we I
think they would have to report on it by
the time you have to finish your work
yeah that's what I'm saying like you may
you may know the house policy on House
Bill 728 if it passes then you maybe
incorporate that into house bill two if
it fails then you've gotta are you g to
try Bill two that's yeah um so last day
to act on bills not in a second
committee is March 20th so that's like a
week before our division deadline
so if I can just add I guess there are
two quirky things that concern me to um
even if HB 728 does not get out of
committee there's nothing to prevent it
from going in
hb2 and that's always very frustrating
rating when you know this one says no
and we stick it in there anyway but
that's just you know the nature of the
Beast unfortunately and the other thing
is um I don't know I haven't looked at
728 but I remember this with Kino I
don't think it pertains to the horses
but that passed primarily because
Community if I'm correct me if I'm wrong
communities had the option of whether or
not they wanted to do Kino in their
community and this alarms me because
there may be communities that do not
want slot machines in their community
and there's no recourse for the Comm
that community
um appetite for this and so those are
the things that bother me when this goes
into hb2 because it just kind of it's it
becomes a bulldozer that just wipes out
other people's perspectives on some of
these things yeah totally fair point I
have not yet read what's in hb2 so I
don't know whether it LS that or doesn't
allow for that but that's a very good
point I
agree okay uh one last question while
before we leave the um unri the budget
summary page 13
um the DHHS HS
recoveries how did that get why is that
like a separated out as another piece of
Revenue it seems like an unusually
small um I would have to look and see
what the general fund kind of normal
revenues are by type it I know that I'm
pretty sure that is usually reported
separately not part of other all right
um but I'd have to look I know it's not
a education trust fund Revenue so I'm
not an expert on that source not our
yeah um so last thing I'll just remind
everyone as far as process when we get
into the heat of making decisions and
having work sessions on votes if you
ever want amendments drafted to come
into the committee ready just let me
know and I can assist with that whether
it's a amendment to House Bill 2 when
when that's introduced or just a change
request to Something in house bill one
we can we can get that done for you so
any other questions on the revenues
before moving from that page
yeah yeah we need your um your what's it
called your crystal
ball is it is it close is it right so I
guess this could be a time to talk about
the Surplus statements that division two
will be responsible for so I handed out
um a little paper clipped stack of
papers the the first page this is just a
reference document we don't really need
to go over this it's just a just for my
reference I don't have them in order
which one you started this is the one
that's Appropriations the government
appropriation division two yeah so this
one is just each agency
um uh buy source of funds broken out
just as a reference just so you know
kind of where the quote where the money
is in our division 2
agencies um so that's unless anyone has
any questions with that I wasn't going
to spend much time on that
the one thing I will just point out I
guess with that is under Department of
Safety I did break out Highway fund and
then Highway fund cost of
collections Highway fund cost of
collections shows up in the budget as
other but that there is almost $40
million and you know per year of that
cost of collections that is essentially
Highway funds so if you make an addition
or a subtraction to those accounts
you're affecting the bottom line of the
highway fund why don't you describe what
goes into that what what are those
collections yeah so so by the
Constitution the department of safety um
is entitled to deduct its cost of
related to collecting and administering
the revenue that it collects so motor
vehicle registration fees driver's
licenses title fees and then the big one
is uh road toll too so the gas tax so
all the Departments costs associated
with administering those programs where
that Revenue comes through they charge
as they take it off the top of the
revenue they collect and then remit the
difference to the highway fund so if
their cost goes up less money goes to
the highway fund and vice versa so it's
just something to remember when you get
to safety's budget primarily the
division of motor vehicle and the road
tool Bureau that's really where it all
is most of it does that make sense
because that can be very I know for me
very confusing How would how would we
know what those cost are put your mic on
and how would we know what those costs
are where are those
and that's and that's where I'm saying
It's Tricky so when we get into the
department of safety's budget um almost
all of the division a motor vehicle
where you see other and then the road
toll Bureau where you see other is is
these two things and um I can send a
breakdown by accounting unit to everyone
so you've got it but it's basic like 99%
of it is there that would be nice okay
thank you but the department as they're
going through when we're flipping Pages
they'll get to oh this account this is
cost a collect so this so they should
tell us as we're going through and it's
a very confusing words to meet that
acrosser collections is a
revenue I think it's
Aus all right so we'll get into the
Surplus statements real quick just so
you can kind of see what I would say our
quote starting point is perhaps so the
one that's maybe a little bit too small
the education trust fund
document um for all three of these for
Education trust fund Highway fishing aim
I did build the governor's proposal in
the Shaded versus division 2 is kind of
where your starting point is which is
essentially house Ways and Means
revenues built on top of the governor's
budget with a couple differences but
I'll tell you about those here in a sec
so in fiscal 25 I just want to point out
three significant um costs that the
division 2 will have to account for that
the governor didn't so on lines um
28 and 32 those are adequacy charter
school and education Freedom account
warrants so what what that is
is I'm sorry on on lines 24 27 and
32 sorry 28 I'm talking about small is
28 yeah
oh yeah the three- hole punch probably
messed with this didn't it
sorry okay so yeah 24 28 and
32 so what these rows indicate or what
they represent is um costs of those
three programs that exceeded how much
was budgeted for them so for adequacy we
know we W $1 million over and I'm
looking at the the first um not unshaded
column 11125 million Charter School is
6174 million and efas was
10.6 so these were amounts that exceeded
what was budgeted but the department has
authority to draw a warrant to make sure
they pay whatever is required by
law the governor's budget didn't account
for those but we know by the end of this
year those are the amounts do doe has
reported those amounts as um as coming
in incoming warrants that they're going
to have to draw so I'm I'm accounting
for those in the division 2 column
which is why if you look you know it all
plays into the bottom line but that that
was essentially 27 plus Million worth of
cost that you've got to account for that
the governor didn't just I'm not could
you yeah just wanted to point that out
um which which ones you referring
to and the other thing I'll just point
out on line 49 there was a $4.5 million
gap adjustment included in the
governor's Surplus statement for the
education trust fund that we've been
working with admin services that we're
not necessarily sure for
budgeting purposes should be reflected
which is why you see in the column
beside we don't have the $4.5 million
there those four changes the three above
and then that is really the only
difference in any of the um
appropriation and uses lines for all
three years between the governor and
division two because that's we're
starting at the governor's that's why
there's no other differences right um
but you can see when you put in the
house ways and means Revenue estimates
compared to the governor's the bottom
lines are very different each year so
looking ahead at the very bottom of
fiscal 27 the governor had about $14
million 13.9 83 million of an education
trust fund Surplus
anticipated the house division two with
where we're at with the revenue
estimates baked in on lines on line 53
in fiscal 26 requires a 26.1 .44 million
general fund transfer to balance and
then another
79577 million so essentially over the
bayum $105 million the education trust
fund is deficit and the that would
require
so um so yeah um a little bit of a
deficit obviously for division two to
start its work um with with those
revenues uh assumed
does this make sense is there any
questions with with this I know it's
kind of a busy document to just throw
throw at you here
but muray yeah thank you um the times
I've been here um we've never had a
deficit as I can recall in the education
trust fund so for me this is the first
time that I'm seeing a deficit I mean
this is draining the education trust
fund can you speak to uh what's happened
before at other times when um we've when
there hasn't been enough money in the
education trust fund to cover the costs
um does that come off first from the
general fund or where are we listed in
that I don't I don't think there's a
like a waterfall or anything like a
ranking but by law the general fund
would transfer in any deficit um to the
education trust fund so when we're
building these Surplus statements if you
end up passing a budget that the
education Trust fund does need a draw
we're accounting for that on the general
fund side so we we will take that into
consideration um but yeah in in reality
if if we needed to balance the education
trust fund with more than what was
available in the general fund that
wouldn't be great obviously but I think
it could potentially bring the general
fund into a negative and then you'd look
at Randy day fund perhaps I think that's
you know my follow-up question pertains
to that um what if Finance as a whole
decides that um can they cut the budget
that we've con that we've constructed
for Education because it's too much you
has that ever happened that they've cut
the education budget at that it's come
from Divi division
two who who's cut it the full committee
yeah um it's it's not typical that the
full committee will will deviate from
what the divisions recommend because our
hopefully our division recommendations
kind of all work with each other um but
but there's nothing you know
procedurally that would prevent the full
committee from making
changes yeah I mean it looks like um
we've got potentially a $700 million gap
and um we're going to work really hard
or we will all work really
hard to support you know the education
and what needs to be done for education
but there's a potential that the finance
full committee could decide that that's
too much for education and end up
cutting what we've put together and um
this I've not seen that but I'm you know
I'm not an expert here but I'm you know
I'm concerned
about having the responsibility of
Education a little bit taken away from
us when the larger committee will say
we're no you need we're going to cut a
couple hundred million out of education
and what I hear you saying is that yes
that is a
possibility I would say it's a a
feasibility like it's it's like it's
there's nothing stopping a member from
introducing an amendment at any time you
know for this well even a floor
Amendment at some point but typically
division recommendations on the budget
tend to hold up as the finance
committee's full recommendation it's
usually not amended but it's not
unprecedented
either thank you um Mickey I'm now that
we're having this conversation I'm
having flashbacks to Mary Heath sitting
on the other side of the room saying
there's been a precedent in the past
where the education trust fund was not
enough and that General funds were
supped supposed to backfill the educ
education trust fund for things like you
know catastrophic Aid at the time I
think was the example she was giving uh
for special education but because of the
overall
budget uh challenges the general fund
didn't fully replenish what came back
into educ education trust fund and so
many of those uh like reimbursements
were not paid in full even though we had
a statutory requirement to do so
uh so I'm just having a little bit of a
panic moment here is that
right do you remember something like
that happening in the past no I I can't
recall the programs that have that open
warrant of not having money available to
it um in the case of like cat a like
special education a that is bound to the
appropriation and there is no mechanism
to draw more money through the year so
that's a that's different than how
adequacy it would be treated for
instance so yeah I can't think of a time
where where that's
happened no problem get all these things
out
now I should say that I misremembered
thank you
Mickey so I will point out one last
thing on this education trust fund
Surplus statement up on lines 15 through
uh 19 these are the revenue adjustments
so the the first section of revenues
that's what the revenue estimates are
based on current law okay uh
representative uh hack and Phillips will
remember that from Ways and Means um
that that those are current law
estimates the revenue adjustments are
anything that's in house bill to that
would change those so the governor has a
few things one being the the video
Lottery terminal uh Revenue we see that
5 million in the first year 58.5 in the
second year because remember this is
just education trust fund the other half
is in the general fund but then the
governor's budget also uh changes the
splits of revenues for business taxes uh
tobacco and real estate transfer so this
was probably an effort in in the
governor's uh phase to see that in in
the governor's plan there would have
been a lot of extra money in the
education trust fund you can see these
Revenue split changes for business tax
alone is like $85 million a year that's
turning education trust fund Revenue
into general fund Revenue so that'll be
in House Bill too we'll have to figure
out uh if Dr if division one or division
two or if it's going to be a kind of a
higher level committee decision of what
to do with splits because there has been
talks about moving other programs to the
general fund again or so that's
something division 2 can deal with um as
we
progress if we're good with that one we
can move to the highway fund Surplus
statement
the highway fund this one goes
landscape so similarly the the big
difference between the uh governor in
the division 2 column is the revenues uh
as well as if you look on page 15 excuse
me line 15 uh the transfers from Surplus
I think there was a 2 uh or 1.9 million
dollar whatever it was uh transfer that
the governor didn't pick up in in their
budget that we picked up here um other
than that it's pretty which line were
you just on line 15 the one that says
9.2 and 10.5 so there was like a
1.29 million doll Surplus transfer that
wasn't included in the governor's
numbers but I've included it in the
division 2 transfer that's already
occurred um2
million2 oh you're doing the math in
your head yeah okay um I was looking for
1 too sorry uh and I will point out we
talked about cost of collections so on
lines 8 n is where you'll see 8 n and 10
is where you'll see how cost of
collections is recognized on the highway
fund Surplus statement so you see the
gross revenues on line seven and then we
minus out how much you've allowed
Department of Safety to spend in their
cost of collections budget and then that
next line is we assume they're not going
to spend every nickel that you've
authorized them to there's a lapse there
too so that's that's how the cost of
collections plays into into the overall
Highway fund picture as it impacts
Revenue uh long story short the governor
had the um Highway fund balance right to
a penny you can see there's zero dollars
left over at the end of the bayum after
a gap
adjustment um putting in the house
revenues and that one other adjustment
um we about six almost $6.5 million do
in a deficit when you hear from dot um
they'll have to explain some impacts to
potential services that their budget
level could could result in uh as well
as the lapse estimate is on the higher
side for each year and they can speak to
if that would impact their ability to
fill funded positions or if they would
have to keep them open to meet a laps
estimate or anything so so when dot
comes in I believe next uh not next
Wednesday the Wednesday after um they'll
they'll walk through
this yeah so on fiscal 27 the Shaded
column all the way to the bottom you'll
see the ending balance is
0 oh right next to it
yeah Mickey will you remind us of those
two questions if we forget to ask do
when they're here yeah when we're I'm
going to try to stay kind of in my Lane
a little bit during meetings over there
but if it helps the committee when we
get to certain things I'll I'll try to
just remind the agency to hey can you
speak to this while you're here just so
so you know we don't forget about it so
yeah that's one for sure uh the other
thing too to to note when not to
interrupt you but just to follow what
you said so what you're saying that the
governor's zero lapse is a very low
lapse for unusually low lapse for the
highway fund no so the lapse is on line
22 a $39 million lapse and that's low or
high that's a high that's a higher than
usual estimate they've they hit that
lapse in 25 it looks like they're going
to hit there in 24 was kind of big but I
think they're getting to that number by
not filling certain positions and so we
just need to talk about continuing that
lapse expectation how that impacts their
operations so if she misses that lapse
then the deficit is going to be a lot
larger correct yeah so if you laps 34
million instead of 39 that's a $5
million impact to your bottom line
correct
um the other thing too is you you
probably have all noticed that dot will
come to fiscal and draw from uh Highway
Surplus for winter maintenance typically
the winter maintenance budget is set at
a certain level and then uh busier than
usual winter could result in them
needing to come to fiscal to draw from
Surplus Highway funds well if the
budget's built on no Surplus they could
they could raise the question of uh well
where are we drawing from if there's
plan of no money in there you know
so can I ask I'm trying I can't recall
when they go to fiscal for additional
money you know for as you you were
saying
um does does that money lap go over from
year to year because I always think
about those years where we don't have a
lot of snow and we're making up for it
this year but I can't remember if does
those funds roll over or is it starting
over again every year uh it it typically
will go no longer than the bium so it
elapse at the end of the bium sometimes
it lapse at the end of the fiscal year
depending on how they made their request
to fiscal sometimes they say just for
this fiscal year we ask for this and
then when it's not spent it a laps
back so that's the highway
fund and then probably the easiest one
here at this point to as far as uh how
busy it is is the fishing game fund
Surplus statement the next the next page
um the governor gave fishing game no
General
funds like nothing in um enforcement
accounting unit which we've budgeted the
last couple terms and then no additional
like transfer into the game fund or
anything so when you notice what's going
on here in the top left cell under
fiscal 25 uh $13.2 million is how much
uh going into fiscal 25 fishing game
fund had and then you go all the way to
the bottom right corner they're down to
you know a million bucks and that's
because this budget is built on them
using their Surplus essentially to get
through uh I would I would say it would
create an issue for the next bium if if
it's funded in this way and there's no
change to uh sources of fund for the
fishing game fund or uses or anything
like that but
uh yeah the way it's built now there's
no General funds they appear they can
balance and get through this by Anum um
however depleting their Surplus doing
it representative Dy what effectively
does that Doe to
them
um they've been this low before it has
um so yeah and then we've helped them
for many years with General funds
um I think it just probably just creates
a little bit of uncertainty for them
building their next budget you know
obviously any self-funded agency with a
dedicated fund would like to have a big
reserve on hand um they've built one
here in the last few years I think the
pandemic helped that um but this budget
the way the governor recommends it is
built on basically spending all that
Surplus to get through instead of using
general funds or increasing fees or
anything like
that yeah go
ahead do they anticipate on hiring any
more individuals I understand that they
are low on officers uh for fishing gain
so this budget is built on a pretty
significant increase so if you look on
line seven you know their budget from
two years ago was 17.4 million and this
goes up to 20 so they've got full
Authority here to spend up to their full
request um so there's no limit on that
their only limit would be is if they
don't want to spend as much as their
Surplus as the governor is built the
budget
on but there's authority to spend and
there seems to be money to spend it's
just they would probably rather not
spend their savings account yeah and
I'll just point out that a lot of Bud a
lot of the Departments of the state
including DHHS and everywhere else we
looking they have a bud a whole big
budget it's you know out of General
funds and they all make it work so the
notion that that fisher game might be
General budget general fund budget is
not a crisis there are a lot of many
dedicated funds that I was trying to
study and I couldn't even begin to get
through them um and it's not clear to me
that that's the most efficient way to
allocate funds because you've got funds
going from like MV into something that
has nothing to do with the dep Motor
Vehicles is like you know why kind of
thing so um it's not the end of the
world if uh if if General funds get
transferred in there by by need and and
fishing gamees not unique here so just
flipping back to the highway fund
Surplus statement you see we start
fiscal 25 with almost 124 million and
end with in the governor's budget with
nothing so it's the same idea there it's
using Surplus to balance these two years
education trust fund the same thing so
it's you've got that um Reliance on the
Surplus to start this bu anym to get
through it for both those budgets
any questions on those
documents do you want to go through the
trailer bill I can point us to the
sections I think we'll ultim I would say
yes unless somebody here is averse to it
NOP
and and we will so for those new to the
process this is the first year that the
governor was required by law to produce
a draft of the trailer bill by February
15th so typically we wouldn't even see a
draft for a couple weeks and then get a
actual introduce house bill to maybe
three weeks after the 15th but this year
we at least have something OS is working
on uh getting this into a bill form and
hopefully we get that sooner than later
um and we that will become our trailer
Bill working document but for now we can
at least see some of the the things the
governor is proposing
so the first thing was the on page 14
the cell phone use policy so for school
districts um to establish a policy in
which uh cell phones are limited if not
prohibited for the school day um the
budget impact of this is there is a
million dollars in house bill one for
this um when the department comes in I
think if you're on page 14 of the
trailer Bill document that second
paragraph that paragraph b um you know
establish a grant program administered
by the department and they can establish
rules uh it's it seems
pretty to me it seems pretty silent on
some of the rules of this like how much
could a grant be what would happen if
there's not enough money what are
reimbursable like a lot of questions so
I would think when the department dep of
Education comes in you could ask them
about that yeah I noticed there was like
no um description of how to rank like
because I assume there'll be you know
how many how many districts are in the
state how many schools can apply for
this grant like how do you know who's
get more meritorious and yeah anyway
there's lots of questions and you can't
just send it to Jael car like that
without a little bit more direction
right I would agree it's it's pretty uh
a generic of an instruction for a
program like that I would think so we'll
see what the department says about that
yes go
ahead I'm probably pretty naive here why
would it cost a million dollars for a
law to go out that says okay at the door
all the cell phones have to stay outside
I don't understand
it um I'm not I'm not an expert on this
but I've heard that there could be some
cost to districts in in Rel relative to
security of the cell phon so if they're
maintaining possession of all the
student cell phones they may need to set
up some sort sort of infrastructure to
keep those phones private and secure um
that's that's the most notable uh cost
that I've heard relative to this um I
can tell you there there are two bills
out there a Senate bill and a house bill
relative to this the Senate bill has no
money attached to it the house bill I
think has a quarter of a million dollars
attached to it so it's it's less than
the million um the department doesn't
have obviously when you get into
estimating costs at a local school
district level it's difficult with the
the wide range of different districts
and some districts may already have
something set up and there's no impact
to them um so that's where it gets
tricky to to kind of cost us out yeah I
guess some school districts have already
made progress in this regard and you can
buy little packets that you put your
cell phone in which is protected from
people trying to you know break into
your cell phone uh still begs the
question of where those cell phones are
in the school with kids and then how you
know how you pick them up how the kids
can you imagine a school of 500 students
is trying to all get their cell phones
at the end of the day and so but but I
think the cost primarily that I
associate with this is buying those
little packets and you can ask is that
our job to do that or is that the
school's job or then you start people
start saying unended mandate or mandate
so it'll be a conversation absolutely
and I just point out my understanding is
it's a grant program so this local
school districts are able to apply for
up to a certain amount or something of
that nature
so the
next if we're if we're good with that
one the next one I think is on page 24
relative to the education Freedom
accounts so I think we heard the
governor say her her plan here but
essentially there's no change to
eligibility in fiscal 26 and then fiscal
27 would essentially have no income
requirement for EFA applicants if they
coming from a public school they had to
they would have had to have been in the
public school for all of the 2025 26
school year essentially and then they'd
be eligible Universal eligibility for an
EFA so it would only be for I think
they've been referred to as jumpers in
the
past and we had talked about having the
children scholarship fund come to
division 2 is that something that we we
want to schedule on a certain day
I don't know about a certain day but yes
and also
um uh what did you ask
about public transportation
oh so that's another one that we were
talking about having somebody come in so
right now I think uh Friday March 7th is
an open day so maybe that could be a day
I schedule some some uh visitors I guess
say some guests to come in and talk
about a couple issues with us
um as sort of a heads up we may well ask
for some um amendments with regards to
this I know a lot of us are very
concerned about accountability that you
only have to apply once in 12 years um I
don't think if there's any other program
where you only apply once with regards
like food Security Programs this is the
only one that you have to do it once and
you're done and so Democrats may be
putting in amendments around you can
guess what they are I'm there will be
isn't that all part of the fun
here surprise you'll be an expert with
no
time did you say March probably March
7th I think is an open day that we have
um that'll probably end up being a day
with some of these guests as well as I
think we're going to get some more bills
off the floor tomorrow so maybe we'll do
March 7th can be all that
so I'll just let everybody else know
that in case you've forgotten as well
they'll know too um I won it's okay it
runs in in the afternoon we do the bills
in the morning um but I do have my
daughter getting married that weekend so
congratul I have so did thank you I have
to travel I have to travel down to
Mississippi for no no no no no no I
don't want to uh I definitely keep this
process going I'm already in trouble for
next week congratulations that's a big
deal thank you yeah yes it is in our
family first one of
four no no no no well in the morning
we'll do do the bills and we'll see how
things run but no I'm not too worried
about it it's I just want to let you all
know so
because I didn't
exactly
Friday so with EFA just reminder there
is a line in the budget for efas and the
governor did appropriate additional
money in fiscal 20 7 to reflect um the
expansion I guess we'll say in the
second year uh when the department comes
in you can ask them about those levels
if they think they're could you remind
us what the yep $ 14.7 million oh in
addition in addition so recall that when
we're talking the the brilliant part in
my my opinion of the governor doing it
the way she's doing it is that it really
it reduces the hit to are costs because
you're basically taking a public school
student who's already getting public
school funding and transferring it to um
the EFA as opposed to the private school
situation where there is no Current
public money going to that so that full
hit that goes with the public school
child is much higher so that's I I and
homeo exactly homeschooling too
sure so in 26 there's 29.5 million
appropriated and then 40
4 uh
29.5 in 26 fiscal 26 and then
44.1 uh so the question about 26 I think
you could ask as well since is is 29.5
sufficient when fiscal 25 was over 30
million okay so I think that's a good
question for the department when they
come in this is one of the programs that
is attached to an open warrant but you'd
still probably want to know when you're
crafting the budget where that where
that lines up with with
estimates since it's been so popular
right it's grown every year so if we're
further expanding it we should at least
be covering what it cost last time I
think at least that seems
responsible uh the next section on the
next page page 25 is relative to the
Connecticut Lakes Headwaters uh is this
our SEC
division so it's tell me I think fishing
game kind of oversees it
Department of Natural and cultural
resources is your Trails Bureau but I
think this is in a statute
that yeah no it's I mean it's
um so this is another bill that um a
very similar piece of legislation is in
the works of House Bill 127 there's no
fiscal impact to this I think we have an
under 10k fiscal note on it just because
they thought there might be an extra
week of enforcement costs um but
ultimately it's a no impact provision
this could be something depending on
what happens with House Bill 127
you don't need to you can just delete it
from House Bill 2 if it's passing in a
separate piece of
legislation so we'll I'll monitor House
Bill
then h on the
HRV I'm trying to remember the testimony
that there um it's potential it's one of
those things that has local impact even
know it's something that's not covered
to the state but in terms of Maintenance
and keeping trails open that there could
be an impact locally or am I
misremembering that or just totally
making it up you know you remember that
too
yeah
yeah we'll try you're talking about this
this piece but I thought it was a
positive local impact because all the
other Trails were open and these are the
trails that like tied them together kind
of thing potentially positive in that
regard but um the continued damage to
the trail becomes more expensive to
maintain and then there's the impact on
local inforcement um in terms of
whatever it is they do when they run
into okay themselves I thought there was
some conflict with like hunting seasons
or something and that's a conflict with
hun hunting so maybe fees or permits or
but there AR a lot of other trails that
are that Vermont is open for that length
of time so I think Crossing back and
fourth has become an issue where they
can't cross into ver they Vermont is
open but main is open and New
Hampshire's not okay so yeah I
think so so for what it's worth that
bill House Bill 127 extending the
closing date for the Connecticut River
Headwaters to Columbus Day passed last
week on the 13th it passed the house and
it's not a second committee bill so it's
crossing over so the way I look at it is
this could be her first delete like you
wouldn't excuse me you wouldn't need
this I don't think you need it in House
Bill too since you already have it
passed somewhere else unless it's an
important enough thing to the house that
you want to also have it in your budget
for protection but
that's uh the next big impact here for
division 2 is the video Lottery
Terminals and that's on page
um it also renames the Lottery
Commission to the lottery and gaming
commission which is interesting so we'll
have uh Lottery um walk through this
with us I didn't see any significant
change to their budget like as far so we
we'll have to talk to them as far as
like their costs associated with this
and um how this could also impact other
games if that was considered for their
other traditional lottery games Revenue
if there's this much coming is that
going to you know impact other games uh
so those would be good questions for
lottery when they come in Friday thank
you um does it happen because this is so
ways and means I'm uncomfortable with
this can we refer this section can we
maybe I don't know I don't I don't know
delete the S can we get this to Ways and
Means instead of us because this really
is a ways means issue and not really I'm
uncomfortable with with division two
deciding and that is a past practice of
house finance is policy issues to send
them to the policy committees um so that
would be appropriate for this and and
like we said earlier was it House Bill 7
28 whatever it is that that could
ultimately end up being your house
position on this so whatever that
happens with that Bill maybe you copy
that language and just stick that in
House Bill too as well that that could
be ultimately where you end up so I know
that is Chairman wier's goal with these
kinds of things but maybe you could just
remind me to talk to him to make sure
that he's aware this is one of those
pieces that we like to in in our office
will when host Bill 2 the official House
Bill 2 is done we'll put together an
index we'll be a little bit more
methodical with our division assignments
and then we'll also recommend a policy
committee so if chairman Wier wants to
distribute you know for their review and
we've done that in the
past uh the next item is on page 42 the
northern Shield we heard the governor
and her address speak speak to this this
is kind of clunky language the way it's
presented here that it says um the sums
of x amount of dollars are here you know
which have been appropriate in house
bill one it's weird to have House Bill 2
referred to a house bill one but it's
fine I think this um account is on page
366 of the the big budget book and
accounting unit
3077 when the department of safety comes
in it's flipping pages and then we talk
about house bill to they'll clarify for
us exactly what's going on here and um
where it is in the budget but I'm pretty
sure that's where that that's located um
and the source of funds for this is
using the um
uh the opioid abatement trust fund right
yeah and you see that as agency income I
think in the budget yeah we've run into
I guess this concept before with the um
alcohol you know the the fund that's
supposed to help people who have a
problem with alcohol and we've as far as
I recall we've never put as much money
into that as we're supposed to this
seems similar to this is this language
the same so that we're kind of you know
I suppose You could argue that it's a
baitman because we're going to have less
drugs in the state which is pretty you
know a silly argument um but do we run
into problems by taking and money from a
fund that's supposed to be helping
people that have a substance abuse
problem and putting it into Northern
Shield just put up you could ask that
question to the department um it may be
a better question for division three to
figure out with HHS um I'm not sure who
oversees that fund I think is probably
HHS s um but I I did look at the
dedicated fund report I think there was
like at the end of fiscal 24 like over
60 million in that fund so it must have
been looked at as a a source that they
could use and
yeah so am I correct that this is less
than the last bium didn't we spend 1.4
Million last time this this is something
new I think that Granite Shield like
that old other program is still in there
too so when you get to those accounting
units more flipping Pages we'll have to
have the department clarify what's
associated with which initiative thank
you I was thinking I don't think this is
in instead of okay
yeah can you share with me what Granite
Shield
is uh it's essentially a program that
was set up to have enhanced um drug
enforcement and Drug interdiction uh
through the through overtime of existing
Troop
as well as the forensic lab I think has
overtime that money that program has
money going to them too so was enhanced
uh drug interdiction patrols and
enforcement that's a terrible
explanation from probably what the
commissioner will be able to explain
much better so so but that's that's the
gist of it and we've been doing that
Granite Shield's been in existence for
several budgets now I think three three
four budgets
uh the next is on page
46 this is relative to the Dual and
concurrent
enrollment that adds that uh the courses
would be up to four credits per course
so there's also another bill it's a
Senate bill that also does something
quite similar to this I'm sorry House
Bill House Bill one 190 193 yeah it's
the lab bill I think yeah yeah so
there's that's another one we'll Monitor
and if a piece of legislation passes um
especially one that I don't think has a
whole lot of controversy you might be
able to just have it especially since it
doesn't have a tie to the budget you
know so but yeah you could end up
deleting this if that if you just want
to support that bill
separately
um page
54 so these are um department of
education related
sections um the first is the education
trust fund law so so this is where um
statutorily um it's allowed to use
education trust funds for which
programs and what the governor's budget
did is um added the Dual and concurrent
enrollment program as an allowable use
for the education trust fund so in the
budget document house one you'll see
under community college system there's
$3 million a year appropriated for um
from the education trust fund it's not
explicitly for that but I assume that's
the intent Shannon can verify that so
that's what that's for
um so this is the statutory language
enabling
that and just let you all know there's a
bill coming out of Education funding as
well that does the same
thing um but there are more subsections
on
that uh section 18 page 54 it's that's
not related to the community college
system but they're new bold text so I'm
wondering so the next the next one so Q
would be the cell phone grant that we
talked about so that appropriation is
out of the education trust fund and then
there's uh something here added for
Department of Education operating costs
in the budget we started this last year
that there is an accounting unit for ETF
Administration which is I think
essentially relative to the data systems
associated with like adequacy and
everything so that's we'll have the
department explain that but I didn't see
anything uh new as far as using the
education trust fund for department
administration than what they're
currently doing I think this is
a just a making it clear that they're
allowed to use the educ trust fund for
administrative costs as budgeted they
don't have an open warrant for anything
like that it would only be what's
authorized in the
budget um didn't we move special ed in
already I think I will have to ask them
what's going on here this is it looks
like they just cleaned up the language
around episod of treatments so and and
corrected a reference perhaps so we had
Corder placement separate from episod of
treatments and it looks like they just
um clarified those two stat statutes
um but it doesn't look like anything new
was done it looks like a cleanup of what
we did last
year the next couple sections um we can
have the department explain the
specifics but my understanding is they
are somewhat housekeeping relative to
Charter Public Schools VX and then uh
something relative to um adequacy with
19841 that third uh paragraph here um
that it doesn't change any grants going
out doesn't change any budgets these are
just um things that uh the Department of
Education said they just needed to clean
up some existing statutes to align with
how they administer those
grants so moving right along the next
thing is page
62 relative to police standards and
training and this is also in a separate
bill uh House Bill 778 does something
quite similar to this which is to allow
for the police standards and training uh
law enforcement Specialists employed to
take detail coverages if they were
available so there'd be no cost here I
don't think to the state in that I think
we we have a billable rate to whoever is
requesting the detailed service but this
would essentially enable police
standards and training Council certain
employees to serve those detail shifts
if they are available and like I said
House Bill 778 does the same thing uh I
don't see a budget impact here so that's
another bill will track and you may not
need it in Hill
tube uh we can ask them I think we have
police standards in next Monday I think
they're coming
in uh Department of Safety um they've
got a few things going on here not all
of which I'm quite clear with what
they're doing but we'll get those
explanations uh the first thing you
remember the fire fund has been uh an
unhealthy dedicated fund here for a
couple of budgets uh they projected a $4
million deficit for this next upcoming
two years the governor actually
appropriated $4 million in general funds
in that account to get them through for
two years um what this section here does
this first paragraph says any unspent
general funds at the end of the year
would just lapse to the fire fund
instead of lapsing back to the general
fund so it's a way to make sure that
fund gets the benefit of that whole for
million even if they don't spend it all
in the first
year
okay the next couple of items we we
actually had director morasco from DMV
here today he probably could have
answered the questions but we'll we'll
ask him when they come in they relative
to uh um driver's licenses and history
uh record checks so we'll ask the
department the necessity for those and
what impact they
have um at the bottom of that page um
emergency services and Communications it
looks like this here is intended to
expand the use of the e911 fund to cover
State Radio communication systems so
we'll have to ask the
department um how the budget reflects
this change here and what the purpose of
this
is um and that that comes from the e911
search
charge the next section relative to this
says division of fire safety so this
this paragraph and then the last
paragraph on the next page before it
gets into State Treasury it looks like
they've identified two positions in the
department of safety that are not group
one that they're trying to reclassify as
group two depending on the member who's
taken that position so we'll let the
department uh speak to the necessity for
those
um yeah the chief of policy and planning
and then that paragraph in between we'll
have to ask the department also it's
relative to um div division of what's
that yeah wheelchair is a division of
fire reading wondering what that was
about so we'll get more yeah I don't
think it's a budget impact here it's got
to be something that they're just trying
to clean up a statute so we'll we'll get
a better explanation from the Department
on
that so the
last thing I have and it's an easy one
on page
69 Lottery
Commission
so there's been boilerplate language in
the back of house bill 2 that has this
same language for years that's relative
to um new games or expansion of games
and um getting fiscal committee approval
for transfers associated with that this
kind of continues on to the next page uh
says that the such transfer shall not
exceed $15 million uh under current law
that exists but it's only $6 million
so it really increases that threshold
what the what the governor is proposing
here my sense is it's VT related but
we'll ask Lottery about that and then
furthermore um this should be in house
bill one in the back of house bill one
so we'll probably delete it from House
Bill two whatever you decide to do with
the language and then we'll put in the
back of house bill one can you speak of
what this achieves I was I was trying to
come up with some the 15 million yeah
you shall not exceed um I just was
completely lost as to I don't know what
it does yeah we'll have to ask the
department when they've really utilized
this over the last few years and for
what reasons but my understanding is
when they during a a year or after a
budget's passed if they're expanding or
adding a game or doing anything there's
a special revenue account that they
could draw from that um through the year
for that purpose with fiscal approval um
but like I said I I can't really recall
how frequent it's been or the last time
so um but like I said the big change
here is going from 6 million to 15
million so there's got to be a reason
for that or expectation of what's coming
yeah that's what my that's my must be
expensive to get it started yeah so when
when the Lottery Commission comes in we
can ask them about that but like I said
I would recommend not having this in
House Bill two and we'll put it in the
back of house bill one whatever you
decide on with the language and I can
imagine it could be a cash flow thing as
well just in terms of sure Lottery and
somebody wins big that kind of thing I'm
sure they need startup funds like this
is what was the discussion if you
remember during the Cannabis uh
discussions uh when it was coming
through the house that they needed cash
to get the program running and it so you
know you have to invest a bit to get the
revenues to come in so that's my
guess so that's all I've got with the
trailer bill um but at least to give you
a little sense of what's in there and
hopefully a little bit more prepared
when the agencies do come in um to
understand what's going on there they'll
they will all be instructed to be
prepared to go through this with us with
their related sections
so
um I didn't really have anything else
Beyond I mean I could have pointed out
some things in house bill one like what
the governor's decision was on certain
funding certain programs we're going to
get to those with the agencies I don't
know how much you really want to do
today um but other than that I can
answer any questions
because I'm not sure the people coming
in can answer the question um I was
taken aack uh with the basically the $10
million cut to the university system I'm
really happy for the community colleges
who want to hang on to that as best we
can but I don't think the university is
going to have a good idea about why she
chose to cut that much and we saw that
there are a few capital projects to me
that does not offset the $10 million cut
to the university um do you have any
insight into the thinking around
that well I can tell you that that was
in the agency budget yeah well that was
that they came was that much yeah
because basically the as I understand
the former Governor asked for a
4% cut and I think that is that 4% cut
that's what that represents I believe
and we also have somebody here who might
be able to even though she's not with
una she might be able to speak to that
particular question do you have to know
what
the
okay it's only un yeah and I'm pretty
sure that's what the university system
the system and and what's the other one
great but I'm pretty sure that's what
the chancellor told us when we met with
her that that's what it was represented
their 4%
reduction anything else
think hacks is really think we I've got
one
Mickey um when I was flipping through
the book it looks like building Aid he
only paying on The Debt Service and the
governor did
not um include any additional monies
outside Debt Service so that you know
was
about 31 or 30 the first fiscal year and
32 the second fiscal year of million
that was not put towards building Aid is
that right uh yeah so the governor's
position on school building Aid is
essentially no new projects for two
years so it would be um just paying the
tail and paying The Debt Service on the
bonds that we issued that's in
treasury's budget so it's just paying
those uh payments on the past approve
projects there is $5 million a year for
the public school infrastructure fund um
in here but the Traditional School
building aid program it appears would be
uh no new projects for two years yep yep
and uh special education Aid you you
heard her talk about that uh so we had a
appropriate approximately what 34
million uh this budget is like around
$49 a. half million per year so that is
essentially
where um fiscal 25's estimate was was
around $50 million so it's essentially
carrying that number for 26 and 27
there's no changes to House Bill 2
relative to the pration or um an open
warrant or anything like that but House
Bill one does have a higher than
traditional level of funding at least
for cat Aid special education Aid yeah
so it was it's like the old catastrophic
Aid whatever they call it special ed Aid
funding yep
um
okay there was no like uh um you know I
remember last by him there was a
discussion of like the
tiered uh reimbursement rates that
that's not that's not here because it's
not current law and um is there
currently a bill still going through or
did it add funding did
that did that get um okay top my yeah
there's a bunch of bills yes many so I'm
trying to remember which ones are left
that we're still considering but yes
we're definitely probably gonna have one
in each of the different
categories there's a bill I think with
an open warrant for cat Aid one that
changes the pration to be no less than
85% I think was another one right
there's a bunch of them and then we're
try to whittle it down I think to to
four is what representative lad said in
terms of sort of covering each of the
topics but we have not gotten to the
Whittle down stage yet we're
close we good
is there
any kind of uh blanket thing you want
every agency to come in with like is
there something you want me to have them
all prepared to talk about or
present no but leave that question on
the table um one thing that um Mickey
had advised me was as a newbie um would
be helpful to do in preparation is to
look through have the the handouts they
gave us when they were here and tie
those into you're looking at the budget
things that'll give us some insight into
what's going on if that makes sense I
thought that was a good suggestion so
I'll let other people answer your your
your question you just asked if you want
to pose it
again well you know this is a different
climate right now but they used to come
in with um priorities things that they
really need and I don't even know if
that's would that be insulting to even
ask them to come into priorities when
basically what we're looking at is a
starvation budget so I don't
know but just be aware you you can see
those the agency budget requests um have
them in there if you want to go through
there which i' I've looked at that as
well
yeah part part of our general thing that
we usually that I usually ask them to
come in with is any significant changes
one way or another with the budget from
previous year as well as any changes you
would like division two to consider so
if there are any prioritize needs or
things they you know after their
discussions with the governor are still
wanting to pursue they they should
hopefully know to you know put those as
part of their presentation but I was
just thinking a line on the lines of any
sort of information you wanted everyone
to come in with to be ready with like
but if if you think of something just
shoot it in an email and well one thing
would would be um dedicated funds that
might be applicable to their accounts
and I think we did get some of that
follow-up information and I posted it to
the division 2 website so I think
they're I think they're all planning on
when they come in especially when you
start flipping Pages you'll you'll
revisit those
um the one I was thinking of is uh
because we talked about even earlier
today is positions as far as funded
versus unfunded for instance just to at
least have a sense of that
yeah oh sorry yeah I was just gonna
agree I just pushed my button in the
wrong
direction so I think I think that is a
worthy discussion for the Departments
when they come in since a fair amount of
them of you know how many um vacancies
are now being like cut or whatever uh
not just un you know unfilled is that
what they call it unfilled unfunded uned
uh yeah so I mean it might be worth
having them each describe like what was
the before number and where are we at
the end and what
happened just to follow up on that um
is that separate from the high rank
freeze that's going on
now you those empty
positions so I I would say if they've
got empty positions today they're
subject to the executive order for the
hiring free there was certain carbots
and and waiver but but yeah that that is
another layer to this is you know if the
governor is got a directive relative to
filling positions one does this budget
the big book already account for a lot
of that unfunded them or is there an
expectation that hiring freeze or or
that that Freez is only through this
year and then starting in 26 it's you
know I don't I don't know so but good
questions for the agency if they've been
given those directives or
not yeah I mean I have to go back I
guess just some of the discussions this
morning of where you know we're looking
at a very meager budget I think it's
considered you know a starvation budget
and then we saw this morning of bills
which would be a heavier lift would
increase the work load on somebody
potentially someone that they're not
going to be able to hire and I would
hope that we would keep some of those
considerations in mind when we're
considering these bills because on the
one hand yes it'd be great to do this on
the other hand we're not going to allow
you to hire someone to do the work
so e
good idea so thank you Mr landrian and
uh we'll close the division two
hearing
e
e e